you know i'm a senior in high school
yeah i always think about my future
every day a lot of people say oh don't
think so far to the future but i feel
like i have to because i want to see
with myself is like five to ten years
from now because my problem i would
think so further in the future i'll
start worrying about stuff yeah i want
to accomplish like i always it's great
to have ambition but if you cast too
much judgment on yourself on a day to
day on how you're reaching that ambition
you're going to [ __ ] yourself you're
17. 18. you're like okay double my age
i'm going to be 36. i'm going to live my
life completely over again and i'm going
to be 36 which is seven years younger
than he is right now if one of you
actually internalized that and said
that's true you'll get patient man you
want to talk about not stressing about
the next five or ten years if you
actually felt what i just said and you
believed it which i know is hard i get
it changing perspective is hard but if
you believed it you'd be patient as [ __ ]
you wouldn't be so stressed